Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier!(*ゝω・)ﾉ
And welcome to Riddle Transfer.
Now this game, JonBro made about four or five years
AFTER the end of Riddle School.
And I believe that this is like a paradigm shift
in his game development.
Like ability and style,
and he came at this.
It said in the development log, it said
that he spent more time on THIS game
than he did on the
ENTIRETY
Of the Riddle School series.
Which can ONLY mean that it's
incredibly, (・ωｰ)～☆
amazingly, (ﾉ≧∀≦)ﾉ
good.( ˘ ³˘)
And I should be able to do it well..
and appropriately.
And apparently,
this takes place immediately after the end
of Riddle School 5.
"WELL, now that your world is saved and our sadistic leader Viz is gone from the universe..
what do you all plan to accomplish when you return to your life on Earth?
Zach..
Wait
OH NO
He's a fireplace now!
He's not..
an icicle anymore.
"Uh..Personally, I plan to find a cure for this fever I've developed...
Drinking a couple thousand gallons of ice water might help a little.."
Smiley (✿╹◡╹)
Good ol' Smiley!
"I'll continue my search for knowledge and use what I know to help others."
Aww~
"Reading the encyclopedia might be fun."
Aww, that's so nerdy and stupid!
I mean smart.
"I haven't really thought about what I'll do when I get back..
I guess what I'll do when I get back, is think of what I'll do when I get back."
Phil.
"As for me..
*pow*
Uh oh
aGHh
uhh
What's going on?
Why are we stopped?
"Something is controlling the ship.."
Well that's never good!
Is it aliens?(༽つ۞﹏۞༼つ)
I mean, it can't be aliens.
Considering we ARE on an alien ship.
Oh boi
"It's taking us off-course!"
It's also coming from Earth..
So where are we being dragged to? (ﾟｰﾟ;)
And why is this against my will?(◎_◎;)
I protest this!(╬ಠ益ಠ)
Very much so!
Even though I kinda did
wanna go to Earth anyways.
So why am I complaining about this?
Are we gonna crash land?
No?
Then everything is fine. ((ﾟωﾟ;))
And okie..
Oh?
Oh, that doesn't look good. Σ((`･ω･Ⅲ))
AW
SSSSSSSSSSSHHHHITTTTTT
NO
Aw, it's the men in black...
What are we gonna do?
AW DICKS
WELP
*boop*
AH
We're boned.( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Oh.
Wa-
Alrighty, then.
Well I guess they can only assume
Oh.
Why does he not get handcuffs?
OH (ง •̀ω•́)ง✧
Cause he's special and they want his powers
AGAIN
Goddammit
They wanted ice before,
and they want fire now.
Doesn't make any god damn sense.
"Well, I was hoping for a new beginning.
I just didn't think it would look like this."
WELL TOUGH SHIT
Get out of there somehow.
Okay so in this game,
I'm gonna A HUNDRED PERCENT
use ma brain.
And I'm gonna use it to the best of my ability,
and NOT. FUCK. ANYTHING. UP.
HERE WE GO!!(๑ÒωÓ๑)
How the fuck do we do this..
Flusher.
Lid.
Oh, things.
"I can't tell if they're doohickeys, doodads, or whatchamacallits."
I don't know what any of that is but that doesn't look like a handle,
it looks like a giant cockroach.
Eugh
Eughhh
Why am I in a- OOOO
Hahahaha!
Okay then.
I got something out of it.
Sink, mirror..
"To be safe, I'm going to make sure I don't even touch that mirror.
Seven years of bad luck wouldn't go well with my two major back-to-back abductions."
Exquisite bedding... poster...
Dial pad...
How 'bout this thing?
Can I do something with it?
Habooski! ( • ̀ω•́ )✧
OH I DON'T KNOW.
1 2 3 4?
"Nothing."
Okaaay, so I don't know the code yet.
Lesse, what's here?
Oh! Σ(･口･)
Well, that's obviously..
Well that's INCREDIBLY convenient.
Why is that there?
"7 8 2 5 5"
7 8 2 5 5
BOINK!
Hooray! \(・∀・)/
I somehow beat the system!
And got out using
the incredibly,
convenient..
CC TV™ here. (Closed Captions TV™)
I don't know why that's there- okay
Where we going- oh God...
Okay, there's kind of a map but holy shit this map is involved.
Not an empty box...
Aw, shit.
Ah, shit dude.(。_。)
Ah, shit how am I gonna get through ALL these boxes?
A blank?
Aww...
Okay- what is that?
Nope.
Oh-oh-oh-oh
It's a train (?)
Click it there, and there, and there.
HEEEY, nice!(*＾∀ﾟ)ъ
I got an elevator key, that's cool, right?
Oh, it's a goat! OH SHIT DUDE-there's been-
backwards nine days since the last accident.
Okay, odd device.
"This thing says 'creature communicator' on the side.
Sounds potentially useful."
HELLO!｢(⑅◔ω◔「)三
HEY GOAT!
OH HI
OH HEY
Uh...
"Why is there 'man' at the end of your name?"
"No idea, I'm just really a goat
I was having the time of my life eating grass and strange mushrooms.
Then I was taken away, mistaken for a mythical creature."
"So you were... 'kid'napped?!"
Ahah
Ah, yeah me, too.
"I'm sad. Grass if my favorite thing to eat in the whole world.
But this grass tastes so bland. It isn't anything like the grass I used to eat.
It's enough grass to last a lifetime, sure, but what's the point if it doesn't taste like grass?"
"I really can't relate to your problem, but I'd like to help you out."
"I don't do my business here in the grass. No grass deserves that.
There's a great little drain in the ground that flushes itself automatically.
I'd show it to you, but it's offscreen."
"I'd rather not see it."
And I'd rather not see that be used because why would I want that?
"What's the random pipe?"
"I don't know, but occasionally soda cans and cereal boxes fall out of it."
"That's really random. Are the cans and (boxes) empty?"
"Every time. Always disappointing."
"Why do you have a smoke detector?"
"The smoke detector is there so I can be spared if the grass starts burning.
*breaths*
I really care more about the grass than I care about myself, though."
"That's probably not a good sign." Alright, talk to you later, okay, ng- goodbye.
So I got an animal communicator- HELLO.
"Zone 5.1 Guard Agents' Annual Day Off."
Oh! *chuckles* Nice!
Oh, cool convenient. Okay, so... I have a key for the elevator.
Which means that I will be able to do what I need to do.
I can access ALL of the floors.
Holy shit, so I'm on F2, lemme go up to F3 first.
What do we got- Did I just slide out of there without walking? I suppose I did, okay.
Hallo!!!(*ゝω・)ﾉ
"No handles, hinges or anything else you'd normally find on a door; no way to unlock it."
Hello! "Hey, pig." "Oh, hello."
"What's shakin', bacon?" "Right now I'm as free as a bird in a birdcage."
Okay- *le gasps* IT'S A FLYING PIG FROM THE OTHER GAME! ((riddle school 3 to be precise))
AWWWW, MAN!
Aww, don't cage him up like that. "I'm not an expert, but I CAN fly."
Yeah, I remember because I saw.
"I was half-asleep sitting just outside this building, and some guy carried me inside.
Then he locked me up here and made me eat like a pig."
"That's a pretty pathetic way to be captured. How exactly do you 'eat like a pig?'"
"I know my etiquette, but the guy didn't offer me silverware, or even a napkin.
So I had to use my feet. Sure, it was fun, but not exactly clean."
Alright, bye. Okay, that was not useful at all; okay, goodbye.
OoOoOh!
No (x4)
OhhhHHHHH!
OH! It's the trash can, from the downstairs. Ohhh...
Ow, *giggling* why did I do that?
*still giggling* Ow, why do I keep doing that?
huehuehue
hehehue
Aight, eventually I'm gonna stop doing that.
That's good shit, good shit right there.👌👀💯
Hello- OH. Hello?(；・∀・)
"Hi Zack." "Myeugh."
"How are you?"
"I'm a little tied up (at the moment). Not a whole lot I can do."
"You have to burn the rope."
I REMEMBER that game, that is a GREAT game.
"I've tried that, the flames on my head don't reach the rope."
"Keep trying, you're on fire!"
You know what the code...?
"...has five digits, and the digits are 1, 2, 3, 4 and 5 but not necessarily in that order."
"The first digit plus the second digit is equal to the third digit.
The second digit is two times of the first digit.
The second digit is half the fouth digit.
And the fifth digit is the sum of the first and fourth digits.
"I'm not enjoyi-" That's literally 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
You literally just said-
ZACK, you're an idiot!
"Yep. The code's just a simple rising set of consecutive numbers."
"Out of curiosity, how could you have known what the code was?"
"It was written on this side of the door."
Bye, Zack! I opened the door if you can get the fuck out on your own,
I sure did it for myself so I don't know why I need to do it for you...
Floor 1, eueueue- OH, no I moved my feet.
UUUUUUAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAᕕΣ(ﾟДﾟ；
AHHHGHHHH!ε＝（ﾉﾟдﾟ）ﾉ
AHHHHHHH!｢(⑅◔ω◔「)三
G'day, sir.
"Salutations, young gentleman. On what subject shall we speak on this fine day?"
"GET BENT, MONKEY DUDE."
"PSH, you ain't got no power over me, punk. I do what I wanna do!"
"What's the purpose of your smoke detester?" (detector)
"Surely you jest! The walls are almost completely coated with wood and vegetation."
"Oh -- I was only wondering if it had any other purposes."
"I do sometimes use it as a dinner plate..sometimes..."
"How do you do?" "My apologies, but perhaps you could sp-spfy (specify)
The nature of your inquiry?"
"What are your emotions in the grand scheme?"
"You told me to remind you not to ask about that again."
"Oh, right. Aren't you going to remind me?"
"Okay: don't ask about that again."
"Thank you much, prim primate."
"Are you fond of crumpets?"
"Alas, crumpets are but a faint memory for this old hominid.
They were treasures to behold when paired with tea leaves of what once was my forest.
It was ba- the day the black-garbed men captured me that I sipped my very last spot of tea.
Unjust judgment can be a depressant like no other."
"'Kay."
Alright, tally-ho.
Don't know what to do with you guys.
It's the shie~up (ship)
"Diz is the only one who can fly this ship. I'll have to free him along with all my friends.
..Not that I wouldn't free him anyway, but he does have the remote that controls the ship...
...as well as the ability to not crash. These things kinda make him important."
Hapididy-boop!
Hallo!ヾ(・ω・ｏ)
Hi! You have hair, that's disturrbing.
Uh, hi.
"I'm guessing you want to ask about my hair."
Yup, 100%.
"Yeah, seeing as you didn't have any yesterDAY."
"It's not like there's much to do when you're stuck in a lil' prison cell.
So I used the can of hair spray that's over there to pass the time.
I'll admit, I'm a bit nervous about what people will think of me now that I have hair."
"I'm no fashion expert, but I say it looks nice."
"Well, thanks!"
Awhaw, they're flirting...♥（ﾉ´∀`）
Okay, anyway let's get 'er outta here.
"Do you know what the code is?"
"5 1 3 3 3."
Ahh...
"The angelr (agent) who locked mumbled out the code and dialed it in."
Well, there's no THREE ON THAT DOOR!
I DON'T HAVE NO REPLACEMENT THREE, SO I'LL BE BACK!
You stay right there, Sally!
Alright, we gotta go down to the basement.
Shibby-shabbiduh!
We're we going? Hello.
'The Negotiable Snowman'. Uh, hello.
"Hi there!" "H-hello..."
"What's the smoke detector?" "It's so the hotheads don't come in and melt all the ice."
"I HATE HOTHEADS." ( ╬◣ 益◢)
"That's some first-class hypocrisy right there."
uhhh... no puns... "(It looks like you) don't have a whole lot of hair"
"I'M VERY SENSITIVE ABOUT MY BARENESS!"
"There's nothing to be ashamed of, I don't have any hair myself."
"Well, that's a nice thing to say, but I don't need comfort.
WHAT I NEED IS HAIR.
Sorry, I just don't have fond memories of when my hair was shaved off.
I'd pay you..a die that I found in a board game box, if you get me my hair back."
"Interesting (trade)..Which board game?"
"(It's called)' Learning-2-Shave'. Terrible game."
Okie-dokie then.
So HE'S got a dice which I could use on the keypad.
Okay, goodbye! (^o^)/
"..Phil!"
"Phred!"
"It's great to see you got out of..wherever you were.
I haven't had the same luck with finding a way out (of this dump)."
"Dump is right. You really got the shaft with this room."
"I really think the people who put us in here just took a bathroom and added an extra wall.
Anyways, I'd really love to get out of here, but I can't do it myself."
"I'll get you out. We could make it a team effort."
"Yep. Since there's a lot I can do behind a wall of extremely dense glass."
Okay, so team effort...
Other stuff
Blablabla
Okay
Do you know.."Snoz".
"What?"
"I'm pretty sure the password is Snoz."
"But it can't be Snoz. It's only numbers."
"Really? I guess this paper I found was useless.
I'm not joking, though. Here. Maybe it means something to you."
Or is it upside down?
NO!
It's nothing upside down!
Unless it' 2 0 4 5?
Which it very well might be.
"This place looks familiar."
"Familiar how? Does it look a lot like your jail room?"
"A little, but what I really mean is, it looks like a school restroom."
"Yea. That makes me feel so much better."
Huh.
That's weird.
There should be a dialpad, but there's none there.
So we need to find a pad..
So there's one more basement to go, and then we've explored everywhere.
So I gotta be down to the nitty gritty-
Hello!( ・_・)ノ
I'm gonna take this hose!
Are you gonna mock me?
Can I have your hat?
Someone else wanted a hat!
G'day!
"What do you want?"
Let's see.."Can I have your hat?"
UGH PFFTTT
No!
"My hat is the only comfort I have.
Not to mention, it..covers my bald spot."
"How are you?"
"I pretty much feel like eating my whole body starting with my head."
"Does that mean you're angry, or you're hungry?"
"Homesick and sick of my home.
I turned sixty-six billion, one hundred fourty-five thousand, nine hundred thirty-two today."
"That's alot of birthdays."
"Oh, but my birthday bites. nobody ever celebrates them.
On my birthday nine years ago, I was stolen and forced to live in this pathetic excuse for a lake."
"Well, happy birthday."
"Pff. Thanks. I'll be looking forward to spending the rest of my life in this--dumpy bathtub."
Oh!
I know what to do!
Ah~I know, I know!
I need the hairspray from Smiley!
Can I have that?
Can-Smiley can I have the hairspray?
Can I have it?
"no, I like being bald. I just think the hair spray will help up escape."
Could you just give it to me?!
Thank youu
Okay GOODBYE!
I DON'T NEED YOU ANYMORE!
I'M GONNA GO GET A HAT!
Hey you want-
(unexplainable markimoo noises)
-hairspray!
Maybe not you?
Is it not you?
No-OH
It's The Negotiable Snowman, but let me-
OOeeyyyy
Sorry to intrude-"Sorry, you're an intruder..
If only I was connected to an alarm system, I could end you right now."
"I don't mean to spread any trouble. I'm actually trying to get out (of it)..
Do you mind keeping your mouth open so I can enter the room you're guarding?"
"My teeth could turn you into coleslaw before you could get through me."
"I'm not the only one who would like to come in, though. I plan to bring all my friends here, too."
"Your three human friends?..
The ones that are TRAPPED?..
I'd like to see them even GET here. That would be worth a laugh..
Actually, I'd get majorly ticked off if that happened..
Don't get any bright ideas."
"Too late."
Okay, then.
Goodbye.
But..There's a negotiable snowman here
that wants some hairspray.
Hello!(ノ^∇^)
(gasp)( ・_・)ノ
OOOOo
AW NICE!
NICE, DUDE!
NICE!
Oh, Thank you!
Okie then.
Thank you.
Have good day.
"Hi there." Hello!
You like hair?
Good.
Okay, goodbye.
I have a die!
nyer
Ha!
5 1 3 3 3
BOINK!
YAY!
You look lovely, Smiley.
"I think it would be a good idea to get everyone to gather at the lowest point of this building."
"Gotcha. I'll be right down."
BYE!
Okay, so I got that!
I'm doing good!
I probably need to get some other stuff..
But I have a power room access card
whatever the FRICK that means.
OH
There it is, ok.
So I use the power room- Ah
That doesn't look good.
"Error"
Ah, okay. Bouncy lines,
thing in th-Ooo
Oh, cool!
I can flush Messie.
Okay.
So I need to be able to flush it,
but good thing I have a flusher handle right here.
That is very nice!
The center pipe is like this;
it will not function otherwise.
So..
How in the frick-a-ohh
oh~
So I need to get..
oh boi
Ah
Shhhhhh
-shit
That's not quite right.
Oh!
I know what needs to be done,
I'm an idiot.
So it needs to loop back through.
This one needs to be here..
and then it needs to loop back-
Ah, I got these backwards. Dammit.
This needs to be over here..
this needs-THERE WE GO!
FLUSH THAT BITCH!
HELL YEAH!
I did it!
Okay, G'bye!
Goodbye!
GOODbye!
I wonder why no one ever brought you
oh shi..uhh..
HAAAA
HA HA
Hello.
Welcome to the place you're supposed to-
Ahww
He was so happy..and now I get a hat.
YEAH!
It's going so well for me I'm actually-
Oh hi.
Hi Smiley.
"I think I was in the library."
"Statement does not compute."
Okay, goodbye!
I got a hat now, so I can use the hat for..
sssomethin'.
Maybe I can use it for, uh
Mr. Bigtoe here.
You want this?
"Does this hat fit your taste?"
"It's nice, but only that; I find it not to be a fancy enough for wearing."
Okay, so I need to fancy the shit
out of this hat..
is what I'm getting outta this.
Did I ever go in this room over here?
There was no room over there.
OOO, I know!
I know!
Oh, I know~
Oh, I know what to do with this hose.
Oh, I-I know absolutely what to do with this!
That's not what to do with this..
Oh, this is what to do with this hose!
Oh~
Oh, hell yes~
"Seems like a good spot,(but) where should the end spot go?"
Oh, oh only down there.
For some sweet chlorophyll.
To make the GRASS grow!
AND MAKE THE GOAT HAPPY!
Oh shit..Oh!
Shit! That worked out incredibly well,
I don't know why.
Okay, alright then.
I'm gonna go say hi to him!
Cause' he's gotta be happy now!
Hello.
"OM (NOM NOM) DELICIOUS."
Okay.
G-Goodbye?
"PUT ONE FOOT ON THE GREEN GRASS, AND YOU'LL FEEL THE WRATH OF A THOUSAND RAMS."
Okay, why did I do that?
W-Why did I do that?
That seems like a good thing to do,
but why did I do that?
Oh, I need a flower.
I need a flower for the hat!
Please, Mr. Goat!
(sigh) I-I need that.
Agh, I need it.
I need that hat!
I need that hat.
Which means I need the pig!
I need the pig because he can fly,
and he'll fly over and get one.
DAMN THIS, I was feeling smart!
hmm..
OHHH
"This is the only flower I can stop and smell without stepping on the grass."
Oh, okay.
I was (mumble) all complicated about it.
Okay, so I'm pretty sure I stick this in-
"I think this daisy lacks the proper decorative flair that would make this hat look fancier."
OH COME ON!
What do you mean?!
Of course it would!
It's beautiful!
This is what I'm supposed to do!
Shut the fack up!
ooOOOoohhh
OH!
AGH
"Before I got tied, I sneezed once, and my whole body burst into flames."
Oh!
That's why it's important to read this stuff!
Hey!
Zack!
Sneeze!
*boom*
Oh, jeez.
See if you got sneeze powers.
That's pretty good. Better than FREEZE powers.
"I have mixed feelings about that escape."
"You're welcome."
"Would you mind following me for a while?"
"Well, I would mind. But you're smart, so I'm sure there's a signifigant purpose to having me follow you."
I do agree."But I'm afraid you can't enter any rooms with smoke detectors."
"I'll be content as long as I get to burn something."
Well that-
That's a bit-that's a bit extreme,
don't you think?
Can I burn the pile of monkeys?
neu
Alrighty then..goodbye.
What else could I burn?
Ah, burn the wood door.
Burn the wood!
Burn it! Yes!
Fire good.
Aw, he's SO happy!
Aw, he's so happy.
Oh, goodbye!
Goodbye!
Oh, and I got some fe-
Oh, this'll look dapper!
Oh hell yea, that is so fancy.
Okay, so we need to go..
TOOOOO
Floor one.
And we're gonna go over here,
but I'm afraid that Zach won't be able to follow in here.
I've got a hat for you, sir!
(gasp)
oh shhhhIITTT
You look so good!
And creepy, and terrifying..
and very terrifying, actually..
Okay, goodbye now.
So this is not the correct one,
but the one is downstairs,
just a little bit to the left.
And there. Slap this bad boy on there.
So, what was the code again?
Snoz, so 2 0 4 5.
Cause' it's usually the upside down thing.
2 0 4 5 ?
Aww..
5 4 0 2 ?
Okay, so Snoz.
So, we're gonna-okay, Snoz.
Alright, Snoz, right? Snoz.
(gasp)
OHHH!
OH!
OH, GODDAMMIT!
FUCK YOU!
Aww man..
It was numbers, which was what I
assumed it would be, and if you look at
it upside-down..It looked like
2 0 4 5.
But I didn't even think..
I wasted like TEN MINUTES!
Goddammit..
It was 5 1 7 0 2 .
Be-aw fuck it..
Here, I'll bring up the picture again.
Look at Snoz.
The S is a 5.
That's- was evident.
The Z is a 2 .
The O is a 0.
That N- the misconception is that N
was not an N.
It- looks like an N, because it's written like an N!
That took WAY too long..
that took way too long.
"Smiley and Zack are waiting (for us) on the bottom floor ."
"Down I go, I'll tell you if I can't find it."
I think we've done good.
That might actually be everybody.
That..In fact is everybody.
So..
Hello!
Hi! We're all here.
"My friends seem to have all accidentally stumbled out of their heavily-secured confinement cells.
We were hoping to have a picnic in the room behind you. Care to let us in?"
"Wait-all of you escaped?
SERIOUSLY?
ERROR THAT IS SOMETHINGHJKL
I WISH YOU ALL A HAPPY NEW YEAR."
Oh no.
"psychotic frenzy"?
Oh shit.
Uh..
What? Do we jump for it?
"I don't think I possess the agility necessary to dive through those chomping teeth."
Well then.
I suppose I'll have to communicate-
I suppose I'll have to ac-
I suppose we'll have to burn you-
I suppose we'll have to-
Oh, I'll suppose we'll have to leave.
Okay, goodbye.
Ah.
Oh! Oh that's easy.
*boop*
Ah! Yeah!
Okay, that's easy!
That was- that was ridiculously easy.
Alrighty..aw, that's so nice.
Yay! Game saved!
What does that mean?
Does that mean I'm only halfway through the game?
Cause' that would be a load of
bullshit.
Oh shit dude.
Oh no.
Oh no, they're stealing his brain!
Aw, they're sucking out
all of it's intelligence.
"Call it a longshot, but I think this machine might be reading Diz's mind.
It even looks like it's retrieving data on the Vizion..
Kind of a drastic method to gain information about a dead project."
Oh.
"Vizion was a scheme concocted by the psychotic alien dictator Viz.
He started this project to essentially destroy the whole universe.
Planet earth would be destroyed had I not found a way to stop the maniac.
Viz got a taste of his own poison, and the project Vizion died with him."
I don't know if he di-
oh yeah, he died cause he got exploded
by a meteor, I forgot about that.
"I wonder if the researchers of Zone 5.1 realize this.
No matter. I came here to free Diz.
And then this journey through injustice will
all be a pleasant memory."
Okay, how do I do this?
Well, that's obviously a communicator.
BOINK!
(gasp)
Good, puzzle panels!
7 minus 0.
That can't be that easy.
7 minus zero equals..
7.
Like..like this?
Heh-hey!
And 6.
Oh, this is way easier than
the other one that I had.
The other one was a ♪biiitch♪
And then 0.
Well, that's super easy!
I like that!
Oh, I gotta make that..
Okay..
Well, this doesn't seem hard either.
Uh..okay, and uh yep,
we're done.
Okay then, we're done with
that one, that was easy.
Okay, so..
oh no.
Not another one of these!
HAAEIII
I DID IT!
I did it! That didn't take forever
this time.
Oh..
okay?
Heyy. Oh? I did it!
That was super easy!
That was like, really easy!
"kinda looks like a whirlpool..Vizion data..Viz.."
Collected data..brain data..
Hey, di-oh.
I did it, Diz!
I'm the greatest!
I've come to save you..
Are you dead?
Is he dead?
He might be dead.
Oh no, he's alive.
Is he? Is that just what aliens do when
they're dead?
They blink and smile?
Oh,"It looks like everyone is accounted for.
And everything at that..I still have the remote for the ship.
Now, marvelous hero.
Lead the way-out freedom awaits us!"
Okay, sure thing.
I don't think there's anything left to do,
we just gotta..
get the fudge out of here.
Right?
Nope, not this one, I was wrong.
Good thing you are all in the elevator.
I just wanted to make sure the coast
was clear before we make our-
grand escape here.
Uh oh.
Oh shit, dude!
Ah, fuck man.
We gotta hurry!
Wait, Diz!
"I'm sorry, but there's no time!"
I gotta abandon all of you.
Oh,"You'll have to find another exit!"
What?!
*clank*
Well, the dick!
I was just joking I didn't think he'd
actually abandon us!
What a douche-nozzle!
Alrighty then, how am I supposed
to get outta here?
Oh, I know how we get outta here.
Oh, I know e-
Wait, this is B2.
Oh, never mind then,
I didn't know how to get outta here.
I was gonna think that I had to re-arrange Messie's tube
and flush us out the trash.
That would've been smart!
That would've been cool!
And that's what I was going for,
but this is just as good.
HE
WHERE'D THOSE KIDS GO
I WANNA KILL EM'
I WANNA MURDER EM'
Oh jeez, don't you think that's
a little excessive Frank?
NAH
I LOVE MURDERING KIDS
Oh, wait we're done?
Oh, I was-I was doing my own thing.
DON'T MIND ME!
I was havin' a good o'l
time making up a hypothetical scenario
where there was someone that was murdering people.
But either way,
that's the end of part 1.
PART 2
Is waiting for us just around the corner.
But we also,
have unlocked
special features.
And I wanna see what they are.
Thought process.
Oh, "I wasn't going to make a Riddle School 6."
"Far too many series have been ruined by unnecessary continuations after an obvious ending."
Well this is interesting because this game was always free,
so I don't think that one applies.
So either way, that is Riddle Transfer part 1.
Part 2, I'll be doing in just a few
days here, I'll make sure that I cap
off the series.
And then this game will finally rest on the shelf
and JohnBro, or Jonochrome, or what ever
his name is, is doing a great job on these games.
And hopefully, whatever he makes next
has just as much passion put into it,
and maybe it'll make him some money in the future
because I think he deserves it,
and I think he could really make something great
out of it.
So,
THANK YOU EVERYBODY
SO MUCH FOR WATCHING
Let me know what you thought down in the comments below,
and as always,
I will see YOU
In the next video,
BYE BYE!ヾ(＾∇＾)
(outro music)♫꒰･◡･๑꒱